So here's Chris, with more friends than approximately 99% of people, 2.5
standard deviations above the mean. Well if the standard deviation is 36, then
what's 2.5 standard deviations? 2.5 Standard deviations, is just 36 times 2.5.
Which is 90, so Chris has 90 more friends than the mean, and the mean is 190. So
190 plus 90 is 280. So Chris has 280 Facebook friends. Another way to look at it
is to use the equation. You know that the z score, which for Chris is 2.5, is
the original value Minus the mean divide by the standard deviation. So if we
plug in the values that we know, 2 point 5 which is z is x, his number of
Facebook friends, minus the mean divided by the standard deviation. And if you
solve algebraically by cross multiplying and then adding 190, you get the number
of friends that Chris has, denoted by x. Which is again, 280. So this time,
instead of converting a value to its z score, we converted the z score to the
real world value.